[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Luis Muñoz
Colonia Guatemala vive en una crisis
diplomática después de que el fiscal
guatemalteco Rafael curruchiche
anunciará que tomaría acciones legales
contra el ministro de defensa colombiano
Iván Velázquez por supuestas acciones
corruptas durante su periodo como jefe
de la comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala acusaciones sin
presentar prácticamente pruebas Pero qué
fue exactamente esta comisión y cuál es
el problema del Estado de Guatemala con
la corrupción para entenderlo toca
retroceder hasta el año 2006 la idea de
crear una institución independiente que
pudiera perseguir las estructuras
criminales en Guatemala era fuerte desde
los acuerdos de paz de 1996 que pusieron
fin a la guerra civil de este país la
oportunidad se dio en 2006 en el
gobierno de Oscar berger quien solicitó
a Naciones Unidas ayuda para combatir la
corrupción creándose entonces la
comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala o sisic que
empezó a operar en 2007
la sisí que era por tanto un organismo
que no pertenecía al Estado guatemalteco
y cuyo jefe era designado directamente
por el secretario general de Naciones
Unidas esta figura tenía libertad de
proponer reformas dentro del sistema
judicial de Guatemala y aunque no tenía
la capacidad de realizar acusaciones
podía trabajar de forma conjunta con el
Ministerio Público guatemalteco
realizando investigaciones y
adhiriéndose a las acusaciones del
ministerio
durante sus primeros años estuvieron a
cargo el comisionado español Carlos
castrosana entre 2007 y 2010 y después
el fiscal costarricense Francisco
dalanese entre 2010 y 2013 esta primera
etapa fue fundamental para cambiar leyes
guatemaltecas en lo que se refiere la
investigación y en crear una estructura
fuerte para indagar en los casos se
destaparon varias tramas pero sin atacar
al sistema el verdadero cambio llegó en
2013 con el abogado colombiano Iván
Velázquez el nuevo jefe de la misión
cambió el enfoque hasta entonces se
había atacado a estructuras criminales
que afectaban a funcionarios de bajo
perfil pero Velázquez atacó a la
macrocorrupción en las grandes esferas
Así que fue Cómo comenzó el caso de la
línea esta investigación descubrió que
se pagaban sobre sueldos a congresistas
para que mantuvieran disciplina de Voto
y en la que se defraudaban al fisco esta
trama involucró en primera instancia la
ex vicepresidenta Roxana valdetti y más
tarde salpicó al presidente de ese
entonces Otto Pérez Molina quien se vio
obligado a dimitir y fue juzgado y
condenado por corrupción yo no he
violado ninguna ley ni estoy en la
disposición de violar ninguna ley voy a
ser respetuoso como lo he sido toda mi
vida de los procesos legales este caso
fue un antes y un después en la historia
de Guatemala la línea llevó a descubrir
más tramas que implicaron a los dos
principales partidos políticos de este
país y los ilegalizó miles de ciudadanos
salieron a las calles a protestar contra
la corrupción y la popularidad de la
sisic Y de Iván Velázquez aumentó sus
investigaciones afectaron a alcaldes
empresarios jueces o ministros algo que
empezó a molestar a las élites cuando se
ASUME la labor con con Independencia con
rigurosidad con responsabilidad
entre lo previsible está que los
sectores afectados reaccionen de la
manera como lo han venido haciendo en
Guatemala en este proceso de supuesto
cambio político ganó las elecciones de
2016 una figura antiestablecimiento que
hizo suyo el discurso anticorrupción
Jimmy Morales se mostró en un principio
a favor de seguir colaborando con la
sisic pero las investigaciones de la
comisión pronto salpicaron a su hijo y a
su hermano y más tarde a él por la
financiación ilegal de la campaña
presidencial que ganó un financiamiento
anónimo genera
desequilibrios asimetrías en los
procesos electorales que no deben
continuar y aquí comenzó la persecución
arasisic en 2017 Guatemala intentó
expulsar a Iván Velázquez y ser que
estuvo un bloqueo de todas las
investigaciones de la comisión al año
siguiente se impidió la entrada de Iván
Velázquez en el país después de que
realizara un viaje y sustituyó a Telma
Aldana la fiscal general que había
trabajado de la mano con Velázquez por
Consuelo porras una fiscal que no
interferiría con la corrupción de la
élite guatemalteca y tras este periodo
de ataques se llegó a septiembre de 2019
cuando Morales decidió no renovar por
dos años más El mandato de la sísic
ha puesto en riesgo la seguridad pública
y gobernabilidad del país sobre todo con
las acciones del señor Iván Velázquez
Gómez aquí en el gobierno de Guatemala
desconoció como comisionado por
recomendación del Consejo de Seguridad
nacional está impunidad se pudo dar
gracias a la unidad de la élite corrupta
pero también al contexto internacional
Estados Unidos gobernado en 2019 por
Donald Trump no se opuso a la idea de
acabar con la sísic es así como llegamos
a la actualidad en 2020 tomó posesión en
la presidencia Alejandro yamatei quien
estuvo preso tras una investigación de
la propia su gobierno se negó a retomar
el trabajo de la sisic mantuvo a
Consuelo porras al frente de la fiscalía
e inició una persecución contra todos
aquellos funcionarios que combatieron la
misma corrupción esto hasta llegar a
Iván Velásquez de nuevo el señalamiento
de Guatemala el actual ministro
colombiano por corrupción ha desatado
una crisis diplomática Pero se da sin
prácticamente pruebas en su contra algo
que ligado al apoyo internacional a
Velázquez hará que no prospere con esto
concluimos Gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de
france24.com
[Música]